One of the things I like doing the most is,
uh, just exposing the hypocrisy or the ignorance,
um, and the bigotry of conservatives. And
usually I wouldn't bring up someone like Tammy
Lauren.
I'm sorry, Tommy, um, Lauren. But I want to
bring her up because of a tweet that she sent
out last night, more specifically, not because
of what she said, but the reality of the hypocrisy
that, um, that she exists in regularly, uh,
on Twitter. This is what she had to say. Quote,
we owe illegals nothing, not housing, not
healthcare, not education, nothing. Now, before
I get to the response, um, from a candidate
for a house seat in Virginia by the name of
a Kaseem Rasheed, I want to point out, um,
the overwhelming, just actually, I'm sorry,
just the, the, the lies and the deception
that is placed around quote unquote illegals
coming to the country. Uh, which is a term
that they use specifically to make, uh, to,
uh, to, to make them seem, it's called the
other vacation, to make people afraid of them.
They're illegals, right?
But the, what Tommy's trying to convey here
is that the same tired, conservative talking
point that illegals, quote unquote illegals
for people listening on the radio, um, are
taking from our society. In reality, there's
a study that shows that, um, undocumented
workers, which in many cases this, this is
who they are referring to. These are workers
who come to this country. They actually work,
they actually pay taxes and they are a net
benefit to our economy. Uh, the institute
on taxation and economic policy found that
undocumented immigrants contribute significantly
to state and local taxes collectively playing
an estimated 11.6 $4 billion a year. They
went on to say that undocumented immigrants
and nationwide pay an average and s on average
an estimated 8% of their incomes and state
and local taxes as opposed to the top 1% of
taxpayers who pay an average of just 5.4%.
So yes, you read that, right? You heard that
correctly. Undocumented workers pay a higher
percentage of their income in state and local
taxes than the top 1%. So this, this line
that all conservatives use, that Tammy is
just the most recent, uh, that they are takers
from our society when actually in actuality
they are net benefits to our society. Uh,
at least according to the study of own institute.
And taxation and economic policy, some of
their key findings from 2016 that's just part
one. I want to talk about the hypocrisy on
top of the fallacy cause shame. Kaseem Rashid,
a quote at Tammy onto a Twitter and this is
what he said. Quote, reminder. Lauren's great,
great grandfather, Constantine Detroit, uh,
was indicted for forging his naturalization
documents. Lauren's great, great grandfather
Gilbert. However, Lauren also came via fraud
since Tommy, uh, Tommy is the descendant of
the quote unquote illegals.
She hates so much. Why? Uh, when does she
self deport? Okay. The last part was cute,
but the important thing here is the level
of hypocrisy that comes from conservatives
with regards to immigration policy in general,
setting aside a, the derogatory term of illegals.
In fact, so many, uh, Republicans, conservatives,
white Americans simply walked through Ellis
Island, right? What percentage of conservatives
are only second generation, third generation,
fourth generation at best, right? So many
of them came through at a time when our immigration
policies were genuinely what you see on the
Statue of Liberty. Give us your tired, your,
you're weary. Uh, w w they benefited from
these loose immigration policies of America's
history. But once they started seeing the
Browning of America, which is not my phrase,
I didn't coin it, I remember it most from
bill O'Reilly when he was speaking to a matter
of fact, I guess we have to play that clip.
Uh, pat drop that clip right about now.
But do you understand what the New York Times
wants? And the far left, what they want to
break down the white Christian male power
structure of which your apart and so on. [inaudible]
and they want to bring in millions of foreign
nationals to basically break down the structure
that we have.
And so he's speaking to the quote Unquote
Browning of America. And once they saw that
the immigration policies started to allow
for the quote Unquote Browning of America,
all of a sudden they had a problem with immigration
of every type. But they also had a problem
specifically with undocumented workers for
which many of the corporations in this country
a benefit. So, so the hypocrisy, there's so
many layers of hypocrisy here. Uh, but the,
the fact of the matter is, is that it's all
a fraud. It's all a lie. It's all an effort.
It's just the politicization of human lives
for the purposes of cheap political winds
playing on these fears of the Browning of
America and other words, America is going
to lose power. Uh, the, the, the general power
structure like bill O'Reilly just said of
white Christian men is going to be challenged
because you have so many quote unquote illegals
coming over the border. It has nothing to
do with resources. It has nothing to do with
giving them health care has nothing to do
with give them education, especially when
we see based on the institute on taxation
and economic policy that undocumented immigrants
pay 8% of their incomes in state and local
taxes
as opposed to the top 1%. So who's really
taking something from America